the good estimates are that the Russians
killed about 30 million of their own
people between 1919 and 1959 you know
and it's it's brutal brutal a lot of
that was through starvation
you know I saw photographs the other day
which I tweeted which is the worst
photograph I've ever seen in my life and
that's actually saying a lot because
I've seen a lot of really terrible
photographs because I've done so much
investigation into totalitarianism this
was a photograph that was taken during
one of the early starvation periods in
in the Soviet Union where about three
million peasants died was a picture of a
peasant couple standing behind a table
at a market selling human body parts for
food like and you know I have this weird
quirk which I don't think doesn't be
much good but maybe helps me understand
things better when I see that someone
has done something extreme I learned to
do this a long time ago when I work
briefly in a maximum-security prison I
try to imagine what I would have to be
like what kind of situation I would have
to find myself in to do that and believe
me man
that's a horrifying enter that's a
horrifying Enterprise because it is
actually possible no matter what it is
that you read about someone doing and no
matter how unlikely it is that you think
you would do that it's possible to
imagine yourself in that situation and
that
well that's enlightening that's what I
would say that's enlightening you know
because one of the things about
enlightenment is is that you get
enlightened by doing things that are
necessary that you really really really
do not want to know you don't want to do
and imagine imagining yourself as a
perpetrator of that sort is tells you
something about the world and it tells
you something about human beings but
it's a hell of a thing to swallow you
know in a very well structured society
like ours where we're so peaceful well
because we have the heat and it always
works and we have electricity and it
always works and we have plumbing which
is a bloody miracle and it always works
you know it's just one of the things
that this imagination process is done
for me is keep me alert to the absolute
miracle that my life is every day it's
horribly cold out there
you can't grow any food you die if
you're out there for 24 hours if any of
this infrastructure was unreliable for
any length of time we would be in
serious trouble and it's never
unreliable it's so unlikely and so here
we are with all this reliable
infrastructure and because of that we
don't really have to compete with each
other much I mean some you don't compete
for food you don't compete for shelter
or some people do but not very many so
it's really easy to think of yourself as
good because you're not doing anything
nasty to anyone but you know a cynic
might say well that that's just because
you don't have any reason to but
those reasons have arisen many times in
the past and in fact they're the norm
not the exception were the exception
this insanely functional society that we
somehow managed to generate is it's
incomprehensible to me that it exists